You have but to ask.
What do you want
with Anakin Skywalker.
He is the key to everything.
To bring balance to the force?
to destroy.
He has long been groomed for
his role
as my Master's new apprentice.
Welcome back everyone is Charlie this is going to
be my Star Wars Clone Wars season 7
episode 10 video probably one of the
best episodes of Star Wars from any
series ever in the history of the
franchise if you're new to my channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
there was a ton of Easter eggs obviously
this is overlapping with the events of
Revenge of the Sith so I will explain
the timeline careful for spoilers if you
have not seen the episode yet we'll do
top 10 and Easter eggs as we go
along starting with number 10 the title
of the episode in the special title
cards and intros that they've been doing
for the last couple of episodes they're
doing this for the last four episodes
with those green title cards that they
put in front of all the movies the title
of the episode is the Phantom apprentice
most of you probably recognize that
that's a reference to the Phantom Menace
the title of the episode is referring to
Anakin Skywalker he's the Phantom
apprentice of Darth Sidious as he tells
us Sokka later in the episode
he's been groomed this whole time to
become my master or my former masters
new apprentice ahsoka spends most of the
episode trying to figure out why Darth
Maul wants to kill Anakin so badly she
knows exactly why he wants obi-wan
Kenobi because he will stop screaming
Kenobi at every turn but ahsoka doesn't
know anything about Darth Sidious until
about midway through the episode or the
impending order 66 plot there are a lot
of key info dumps during the episode
that shake her to her core and because
we're on the eve of order 66 going down
I'm really happy that Dave Filoni
doesn't keep her in the dark on
everything there's still some important
details she hasn't quite figured out yet
but for her and all this in these final
episodes half of this is about what's
going on with Anakin Skywalker and the
other half as what's going on with the
clone troopers in order 66 her friends
like Rex they're getting ready to
experience all this tragedy from a whole
different perspective the reason why
they're using those special green tidal
cards and the special intros
for these final four episodes in the way
that they're titling them part 1 part 2
part 3 in part 4 is because the story of
these final four episodes is partly
based on George Lucas's expanded story
and deleted scenes from Revenge of the
Sith ideas that just didn't have time
for or space for in the movies and
because these are so interconnected with
Revenge of the Sith crossing over with
movie scenes they're treating the final
four episodes as if they were part of
the movie itself like this and Revenge
of the Sith edited together correctly
for the timeline is meant to be a four
hour movie instead of just being a two
hour movie so number nine Darth Maul
reveals Darth Sidious his grand plans
for the galaxy too ahsoka the first time
they meet they don't waste any time he
talks about it and they don't really get
into specifics till later but he tells
her that Darth Sidious is the new world
new galactic order behind all this
obi-wan Kenobi confirms this later Count
Dooku once spoke to me of a Darth
Sidious but Anakin has just killed him
so we really don't have a whole lot of
information about it Maul even laughs at
ahsoka when she talks about bringing him
in before the council and asking for his
help in stopping Darth Sidious if it's
such a big problem why don't you help us
we can take down this threat together
and he's like you don't understand
there's not even going to be a Jedi Council
in a couple days the really interesting
thing that sam witwer who's doing the
voice of Darth Maul and Dave Filoni do
with Maul in this episode is that when
he's talking about Darth Sidious as new
Galactic Empire these creating there's a
hint of fear in his voice like he's
still very much afraid of the emperor
who actually at this point in the
timeline of Revenge of the Sith hasn't
declared himself Emperor yet I'll
explain the timeline in a second but
remember the last time we saw him he was
taken by Darth Sidious he was saved by
the Mandalorian super commandos that he
references later you saved me from that
prison the Darth Sidious had thrown me
in the other crazy thing about Maul
during this whole episode is that
despite the fact you can clearly tell
he's lost his mind just a little through
all the crap that he's been through he
genuinely wants to stop Darth Sidious
and save the galaxy from his threat not
out of a desire to be heroic or anything
good purely is an act of
self-preservation because he is on the
Emperor's hit list the emperor would
just keep sending assassins after him
so he and the Jedi have some common
ground don't worry I'll get to the high
ground memes in a
second because there were some really
cool high ground references later in the
episode he and ahsoka as he says later
share even more in common because
they're both fallen apprentices who left
their masters although Darth Maul didn't
do it by choice you could tell how
bitter he was being cast aside for Count
Dooku but then he's like no wait I
realized it now Dooku was just a pawn too
for someone else paving the way for
Anakin Skywalker so number eight The
Revenge of the Sith timeline the episode
did a pretty good job of placing itself
in the timeline most of you are probably
able to figure out where it was based on
a couple key scenes where characters
talked about what just happened during
Revenge of the Sith is obi-wan Kenobi
states later this episode picks up right
after Anakin and obi-wan had rescued
Palpatine from general Grievous's ship
in the opening scene of Revenge of the
Sith Anakin has already killed Count
Dooku taking Palpatine's bait got him
now do it now the Jedi Council has just
ordered him to spy on Palpatine all part
of Palpatine's grand plan to make anakin
hate and distrust the council more and
more making the decision to join him on
the dark side that much easier
so as of the end of the episode we have
not gotten to the infamous Darth
Plagueis the wise scene at the Opera and
Anakin still hasn't learned Palpatine is
Darth Sidious 7 Darth Maul rips all that
information on order 66 from the clone
troopers mind so before he used his
powers to learn the full truth of what's
going on he knew Palpatine had a plan to
take over the galaxy
because during Phantom Menace you hear
him talking about how it's time for
their revenge
obviously Revenge of the Sith is when
that revenge actually goes down this
scene though is more about Maul getting
the exact details in the timing of it
all like it's happening right now
literally the next couple of days it
is going down that's why right after
this moment he skypes the rest of the
crime syndicate telling them to vanish
themselves for a hot minute till
everything blows over and the Emperor's
dirty work is done number 6 the Republic
and Boca tans forces retake Mandalore
from Darth Maul so this isn't the end of
it but the Mandalorians real goal here
is to just get their planet back they're
not really involved in the Clone Wars at
the moment but we'll see how that
changes because there's also a lot of
this history that they referenced during
the Mandalorian
season 1 the live-action series during
episode 8 of that series Moff Gideon
references his history in the Imperial
Security Bureau in the Mandalorian
sector in the Great Purge that the
Mandalorians reference on that series is
not the same thing as order 66 it's a
completely different event but one that
had a very similar effect so while most
of the attention of the animated series
is building to order 66 which PI happens
in the finale I'm hoping that they also
referenced the Mandalorians Great Purge
somehow too or somehow foreshadow that so
early prediction on how that goes down
the Emperor after purging the Jedi Order
tries to compel the Mandalorians in
Bocca tan to join the Empire when they
refused he probably orders them to be
purged as well in all their assets and
resources seized that's how the Empire
got their hands on all that best car we
saw during the Mandalorian episode 3
they stole it from Mandalore when they
purged the Mandalorians so number 5
Darth Maul in the syndicate the cool
shadows of the Empire Easter Egg a lot
of you probably noticed was the fauline
here on the left he looks just like
princes is ER and based on the timeline
it is possible that this is Prince
sizzurp but I think that he's a little
bit younger at this point in the
timeline because he didn't die till 3
years after a new hope that's way later
in the timeline from when this moment is
happening and he's not that old during
shadows of the Empire so this might just
be another fall lien but the criminal
empire that they run is called Black Sun
the one that Darth Maul runs is called
crimson dawn there are many different
crime syndicates but at this point in
the timeline Darth Maul has managed to
pool all their resources and combine
them in a loose alliance sort of
separate from what's going on between
the separatists in the Republic and the
Clone Wars so all the crime syndicates
are really just trying to play both
sides for profit during this war which
is Darth Maul says is getting ready to
end really fast so they're all going to be
put on the Emperor's hit list so that's
why they all need to just disappear for
a little while for the final battle of
Mandalore Darth Maul gives a really good
motivational speech to those super
commandos he gives them a really
compelling argument during the episode
basically promising them an honorable
death in battle which is all the
Mandalorians really care about freedom
and a glorious death worthy opponents
which Bo Catan in her offshoot of the
Death
Mandalorians are happy to oblige so I
love the way the Dave Filoni edited the
big final battle with ahsoka in Darth
Maul's fight scenes jumping back and
forth between the different fight scenes
number three
ahsoka versus Darth Maul round one you
probably noticed the really big Empire
Strikes Back reference here and their
first big fight scene where he says join
me and we can defeat Darth Sidious it's
obviously a reference to Darth Vader and
Luke Skywalker during Empire Strikes
Back where he says join me and we can
defeat the Emperor he tries to appeal to
her by saying that they share a lot in
common
we were both cast aside by our masters
even though it's technically not true in
her case Anakin didn't want her to go
she left the Jedi Order by choice Darth
Maul as he says a couple times during
the episode was cast aside by his master
ahsoka also makes a really clever Anakin
Skywalker Revenge of the Sith reference
where she tells him your visions are
flawed when he starts talking about how
Anakin is going to be responsible for
destroying the Jedi both Darth Maul and
Anakin wouldn't want to listen to anyone
telling them their visions aren't 100%
accurate and might be potentially
misleading with Anakin his visions
become a bit of a self-fulfilling
prophecy
the actions that he takes directly lead
to the outcome in his visions that he's
trying to avoid Padme winding up dying
on the hospital bed
whereas if he had rejected the Emperor
she might have survived even though they
imply there is no stopping order 66 like
Darth Maul says several times in the
episode there is nothing you can do
Darth Sidious his plan is airtight he is
going to win this fight but number two
we have to talk about the actual fight
scene just from a purely technical
animation perspective how amazing does
this scene look really you could say
that about all the scenes in these final
four episodes it feels like they
animated them on a level that's so far
beyond even the rest of the season seven
episodes but look at the quality of this
animation compared to some of the
earlier seasons of the Clone Wars back
what it was on Cartoon Network it's like
night and day it's like a completely
different show in the really cool thing
about these episodes is that they
actually make Revenge of the Sith a
better movie it's a lot like rogue one
making a new hope a better movie by
adding information and context so number
one round two on the catwalk you
probably noticed The Return of the Jedi
Easter eggs here and the high ground
reference when Darth Maul
one last chance it's a reference to
Darth Vader fighting Luke Skywalker on
the catwalks in the Death Star saying if
you can't be turned then you'll be
killed they even break that support beam
just like Darth Vader destroys the
catwalk except it's a big high ground
twist so ahsoka gains the upper hand
even though she doesn't say that she
doesn't do the obi-wan meme but it ends
very similarly with him yelling at her
let me die I hate you so much
and then they suppress and take him into
custody but remember this is all before
the Darth Plagueis the wise memes in
Palpatine revealing himself to Anakin so
that'll probably be addressed in next
week's episode there's still two more
episodes so my assumption is is that the
finale is going to be order 66 in the
events immediately after Revenge of the
Sith as a sort of epilogue to explain
what happens to a Sokka next and then
obi-wan Kenobi with Luke and Leia but if
you spotted any big Easter eggs in the
episode that I didn't mention in the
video just write them below in the
comments and what will happen is my
episode 11 video will just post next
week everyone click here for my
Mandalorian season 2 teaser trailer and
season 3 details and click here for my
brand-new Avatar The Last Airbender
Netflix video thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe.
I'll see you guys tonight!